like vehicles ever seen in the Star Wars
galaxy x-wings a wings TIE fighters and
interceptors and of course the
Millennium Falcon these fast-paced
aerial battles will take you from the
highest altitudes above each planet all
the way down to frantic chases through
dangers terrain and to make things even
more epic there will be an additional 20
AI starfighters in in disguise adding
even more excitement to the battle all
of this combines to deliver the most
intense Star Wars dog fights ever in a
video game and for those of you here at
Gamescom you'll be able to play Fighter
Squadron this week for the very first
time
you also saw all of the action taking
place from Sullust a previously
unexplored planet in the Star Wars
universe working closely with Lucasfilm
our team of dice have been given the
privilege of creating the visual
identity for solaced as huge star wars
fans I can't tell you how honored our
team is to know that you will get your
first true look at Sullust in Star Wars
Battlefront and not only does it look
exciting the gameplay is action packed
from intense dogfights to epic ground
battles Sullust provides a number of
great locations including lava fit
landscapes and the hangars where the
Empire pins and houses their war
machines we have a loft left to show you
before Star Wars Battlefront launches
this November including new modes Maps
characters and more until then here's
another look at just some of the Star
Wars battle fantasies that await you
thank you
you